you
good afternoon it's it's an honor to
introduce to you our speaker for this
afternoon mr. Craig surely Craig surely
is the president of Shirley and banister
public affairs and has also previously
been a contract agent for the CIA mr.
Shirley has worked in government and on
campaigns at the gubernatorial
congressional and presidential level a
graduate of Springfield College where he
was chosen in 2005 is outstanding
alumnus his fields of specialization
range from strategic public relations
crisis management and marketing as well
as political consulting and government
affairs he was named the first Reagan
scholar at Eureka College Ronald
Reagan's alma mater and also serves as a
member of the Board of Governors at the
Reagan range he has written extensively
for the Washington Post The Washington
Examiner the Washington Times the Los
Angeles Times the Weekly Standard and
many other publications he is also the
author of Reagan's revolution the
Reagan's revolution the untold story of
the campaign that changed the dull and
rendezvous with destiny Ronald Reagan
and the campaign that changed America
you can also keep an eye out for his
newest upcoming book which will be out
this fall called December 1941 three
days that changed America and saved the
world would you please join me in giving
a warm welcome to mr. Craig Shirley
I always admire people who are able to
get up in front of an audience to speak
extemporaneously without notes oh that's
that's a real talent Danny well done
thank you for that kind introduction in
considering all the great men women of
the world and of letters who have spoken
here at Hillsdale Ronald Reagan Jeanne
Kirkpatrick at fullner and at nice just
to name a very few you've given my wife
serene and me and honor in a memory
which will live in our hearts forever
and I would like to introduce my wife
serene stand up she deserves that round
of applause because we just celebrated
our 30th anniversary and and also the
best editor I've ever worked with thank
you let me say it's a real pleasure to
be here one of you academic institutions
in America where the professors and the
students actually know the difference
between Friedrich Hayek and Salma Hayek
it surely in bannister public affairs we
have a Hillsdale graduate on our staff
Jameson Cunningham his professionalism
and demeanor represent well the
excellence of this institution and I
know the school is proud of him and all
of his accomplishments and all of us
accomplishments yet to come he
represents the school very well in case
there's any doubt let me also say for
the record I favor Reagan over Cicero on
the liberty walk but I suspect Reagan
would equip that he would prefer himself
because while he Reagan quoted Cicero
Cicero never quoted Reagan
as Kim would know I recently read a
thoughtful piece by a collegian reporter
Jody westrick on the matter of who
belongs and who does not belong in
liberty walk and I agreed with her
observations that Lincoln Jefferson and
Frederick Douglass also belong there
Jeff was most impressed to learn the
Frederick Douglass had spoken here back
in the 1860s all belong there these were
men of great letters and great ideas
were great and courageous freedom
fighters Douglas the old Republican was
on his deathbed a young man came to him
and asked his career advice and the old
man said to the young man he said
agitate son agitate agitate agitate all
the great freedom fighters of history
challenged the status quo including and
especially the subject of this
conference as dr. Larry iron pointed out
an eloquent tribute to President Reagan
when the Gipper died Reagan always
challenged conventions and was really
the last President to know the power of
ideas and the power of the spoken word
like Cicero Reagan was also a great
order and a threat to the establishment
Reagan and Cicero thought about things
as our old friend Russell Kirk who was
from right here in Michigan once said
from the moment I began to reason and
possibly from the hour I began to feel I
have been a conservative American
conservatism and Reagan's campaigns were
always about the expansion of freedom
back in nineteen eighty-four Reagan told
some friends of Hillsdale quote the tide
of freedom is a future tide this was
revolutionary thinking even as of 1984
with an evil empire still very much evil
and still very much an empire and with
an opposing party in America whose
nominee only 12 years earlier said he
would crawl on his hands and knees to
the Communists thugs in Hanoi George
McGovern had also attacked John Foster
Dulles in the 1950s accusing him of
wanted to destabilize the Eastern Bloc
as if this was a bad thing Jimmy Carter
that's true Jimmy Carter the 39th
president said in 1977 at Notre Dame do
we had to get over our norden
of communism the prospects of his
reelection terrified millions of
americans who feared for the economic
and political futures so naive was he
about this country and the Soviet threat
George will once told me that for the
first time in his life he considered the
election of 1980 a national emergency
had Jimmy Carter been re-elected it's
not outside the realm of possibility
that our children would be writing a
Cyrillic and we'd all be looking forward
to a bowl of borscht for supper tonight
Reagan concluded those remarks to the
Hillsdale friends saying Hillsdale
deserves the appreciative all who labor
for freedom your creative outreach he
said enables little Hillsdale to cast
such a long shadow even as far back as
1977 Reagan was here walking these halls
breathing this air embracing and
articulating a vision of maximum freedom
consistent with law and order greatness
still awaited him but he was thinking
and developing great thoughts these were
his wilderness years and it seems very
appropriate that he would come to
Hillsdale on that time though Reagan was
in the wilderness these were extremely
productive years for him his daily
5-minute commentaries were heard by
millions as twice week column was read
by as many he was organizing and
fomenting and leading a political
revolution against the Panama Canal
treaties for tax cuts for a whole myriad
of issues that were reorganizing and
redeveloping the Republican part into
something that really quite frankly
didn't want to be it was philosophy and
created a political movement that was
changing the arc of history even today
we read about political campaigns such
as one recently in Mongolia where
candidates said he was modeling his
campaign on Ronald Reagan's in my first
two books about reg and I spent
considerable time examining Reagan's
wilderness years as these were so
important in this development of growth
writing books about Reagan allows one to
meet people from all walks of life along
along with learning about their own
interesting perspectives had the chance
to speak at eureka college and the
reagan library and the reagan ranch i
would urge you to go to all of them
campuses around the country
but earlier this year I participated it
up conference at Eureka on Reagan and
the Midwest and how his Midwest
upbringing said it had changed or
created his character I was that night
after the first night of proceedings I
was staying it up hotel in Peoria which
is about 20 miles from Eureka who's
about eleven o'clock at night it was
about 20 degrees out I was outside
having a cigarette yes I smoke and was
about eleven o'clock and this old wino
sidles up to me and bums a cigarette
from me and he says it asked me if I was
from Peoria and i said no i'm in town
pretending up conference at eureka this
long pause and says eureka as a rail
regan when the topic of my discussion of
the three elections of Ronald Reagan
I'll truth be told you ran four times
including in 1968 when he came far
closer defeating Richard Nixon to miami
beach for the than most people realize
the subject actually is so fascinating
my publishers added it to the four more
books i plan to write about ronald
reagan at this time would like to show
you a short film which was prepared for
my book on the ad campaign this way to
reassociate you with that monumental and
event making election after which i'll
make a few more remarks and then take
any questions that you might have is my
friend Ted up there there we go
Ted this convention full of things we've
never seen before including
these two
in chastity
together including one contestant who
the thing I'm both
there
there are cynics who say that a party
platform is something that no one
bothers to read and it doesn't very
often amount to much whether it is
different this time that it has ever
been before I believe the Republican
Party has a platform that is a banner of
bold unmistakable colors with no pale
pastel shades
here in this hall tonight better than
we've ever done before we've got to quit
talking to each other and about each
other and go out and communicate to the
world that we may be fewer in numbers
than we've ever been but we carry the
message they're waiting for we must go
forth from here United determined that
what a great general said a few years
ago is true there is no substitute for
victory mr. president
good evening I'm here tonight renounce
my intention to seek the Republican
nomination for President of the United
States I'm sure that each of us has seen
our country from a number of viewpoints
depending on where we've lived and what
we've done for me it's been as a boy
growing up in several small towns in
Illinois as a young man in Iowa trying
to get a start in the years of the Great
Depression and later in California for
most of my adult life I've seen America
from the stadium press box as a
sportscaster as an actor officer of my
labor union soldier officeholder and as
both Democrat and Republican we who are
privileged to be Americans it had a
rendezvous with destiny since the moment
in 1630 when John Winthrop standing on
the deck of the tiny Arbella off the
coast of Massachusetts told the little
band of pilgrims we shall be as a city
upon a hill the eyes of all people are
upon us so that if we shall deal falsely
with our God in this work we have
undertaken and so cause him to withdraw
his present help from us we shall be
made a story and a byword throughout the
world for our country's future I pledge
you my every effort I ask for your
prayers and your support I believe that
together we can keep this rendezvous
with destiny thank you and good night to
make an announcement video where the
song man please terms the writings my
papa
is this a mr. green you turn up my
viewers for me if you paying for this
microphone
you
we're using up prime time mr. chairman
mr. vice president to be this convention
my fellow citizens of this great nation
with a deep awareness of the
responsibilities conferred by your trust
I accept your nomination for the
presidency of the United States
the administration which has brought us
to this state is seeking your
endorsement for four more years of
weakness indecision mediocrity and in
competence no no American should vote
until he or she has asked is the United
States stronger and more respected now
than it was three and a half years ago
it's impossible to capture in words the
splendor of this vast continent which
God has granted as our portion of his
creation there are no words to express
the extraordinary strength and character
of this breed of people we call American
everywhere everywhere we've met
thousands of Democrats independents and
Republicans from all economic conditions
all walks of life bound together in that
community of shared values of family
work neighborhood peace and freedom
they're concerned yes they're not
frightened they're disturbed but not
dismayed they are the kind of men and
women Tom Paine had in mind when he
wrote during the darkest days of the
American Revolution we have it in our
power to begin the world over again
nearly nearly 150 years after Tom Paine
wrote those words an American president
told the generation of the Great
Depression that it had a rendezvous with
destiny I believe this generation of
Americans today also has a rendezvous
with destiny fellow Democrat
fellow citizens I thank you for the
nomination you've offered me
with gratitude and with determination I
accept your nomination
but the answer to their question is I'm
here because it is the home of Democrats
because I believe today that in this
country there are millions of Democrats
who are just as unhappy with the way
things are as all the rest of us are
it's not inconceivable that the election
could turn on what happens in the next
90 minutes Reagan the former two-term
Governor of California former motion
picture actor three times a candidate
for president and this time the
Republican nominee with them lending the
considerable support which has been her
trademark his wife Nancy and Jimmy
Carter former governor of Georgia peanut
farmer the Jimmy who who stunned the
political establishment in 76 by winning
the white house now Carter's trying to
retain it with a lot of help from his
wife Rosalyn one of his most energetic
campaigners I had a discussion with my
daughter Amy the other day before I came
here to ask her what the most important
issue was she said she thought nuclear
weaponry governor Reagan again typically
is against such a proposal governor
there you go again that was his greatest
weakness Robert reluctant as I
understanding critical about Governor
Reagan i'll try to answer your question
next Tuesday is election day next
Tuesday all of you will go to the polls
who stand there in the polling place and
make a decision I think when you make
that decision it might be well if you
would ask yourself are you better off
than you were four years ago during this
last year I've had a chance to meet and
talk on the campaign trail with
Americans in every corner of the United
States I find no national melees I find
nothing wrong with the American people
oh they're frustrated even angry at what
has been done to this blessed land but
more than anything they're sturdy and
robust as they've always been at this
very moment some young American coming
up along the Virginia or Maryland shores
of the Potomac is seeing for the first
time the lights that glow on the great
halls of our government and the
monuments to the memory of our great men
let us resolve tonight but young
Americans will always see those Potomac
lights that they will always find their
a city of hope in a country that is free
and let us resolve they will say of our
day and of our generation that we did
keep faith with our God that we did act
worthy of ourselves that we did protect
and pass on lovingly that shining city
on a hill I promised you I promise you
four years ago that I would never lie to
you so I can't stand it or night and say
it doesn't hurt so Jimmy Crocker the
defeated president
shakes hands with some of his well
wishers as he leaves the hotel ballroom
in Washington presumably to return to
the White House this is an ABC news
special the 80 vote election night here
is the Electoral College status as of
right now with 270 needed Ronald Reagan
is way over the top 416 to 49 for
President Carter non for congressman
Anderson it is in truth a Reagan
Republican landslide sweeping across
this nation tonight let me just say
first of all this has been well there's
never been a more humbling moment in my
life not only humbled by the extent of
what has happened tonight even if it had
been the cliffhanger that all of us I
think we're expecting I consider the
trust that you have placed in me sacred
and I give you my sacred oath that I
will do my utmost to justify your faith
earlier this evening I spoke on the
phone with President Carter he called
john addison called but the president
pledged the utmost in cooperation in the
transition that will take place in these
coming months i offered him my own
cooperation he graciously said that he
wanted this to be the
he's governor Reagan we just wanted to
show you what the map of the United
States looks like as of eight o'clock
tonight hey
Oh
you
alright
when that when that began to slide I
thought that maybe the world was going
out just as I was getting in and now as
I said before my family I'm so grateful
to them for the love for their support
and for the hard work because some of
them are out on a campaign trail easily
as much as Nancy and I were the speaking
of Nancy she's going to have a new title
in a couple of months
and it isn't really new because she's
been the first lady in my life for a
long time
I have one message that i have to give
before I leave I've been upstairs on the
phone trying to get ahold of two
celebrations two parties that are going
on one in tampico Illinois where I was
born and one in Dixon Illinois where I
grew up I've got to hometowns and
finally we managed to get the radio
station in that area and they told us
that they were brought would broadcast
my message into the two parties that are
going on so do all of them thank you to
back there in the home time thank you
governor are you prepared to take the
constitutional I am if you place your
left hand on the day of Bible and raise
your right hand and repeat after me i
Ronald Reagan do solemnly swear i Ronald
Reagan do solemnly swear I believe that
together we can keep this rendezvous
with destiny
yeah I always enjoy watching that is the
back story about the cake and election
that was that it was not planned who's
not requested is not organized and the
young man 30 years ago is probably now
my age was never heard from again Randy
Reagan administration they were not mrs.
Reagan was not very happy about it
neither were a lot of other people but
anyway campaigns were a lot different in
those days there was a lot more
unscripted moments like that than they
are than they are now but there are a
lot more fun in those days to Reagan
regarded the election of 1980 as the
fourth American Revolution it must be
seen as one for most important elections
in American history along with 1800 1860
and 1932 each of these national
plebiscites offered a startling new
choice and direction for the American
voter and the consequences of each
election were profound but it was only
in this election in 1980 that his
philosophy was fully formed fully
developed and fully presented to the
American people yet poorly understood by
the elites then and now to them it was
always about as cheerfulness yet in a
callous sort of interpretation never
understanding the cheerfulness that came
from his faith and belief himself and
the American people in the future
American exceptionalism was not just a
phrase to rake and he understood it
indeed lived it with every fiber of his
being Reagan understood what was at
stake in 1980 that truly was a malaise
which had descended upon the country we
were losing a Cold War the Soviet Union
had invaded Afghanistan much of Central
America and all of southeastern Asia
Asia had fallen to communism Cuban
troops were in Angola Russian nuclear
subs and troops were in Cuba NATO was
falling apart President Carter seemed
ill-equipped to understand the threat as
he later admitted to a network in a
network interview with Barbara Walters
of the ferocity of
Moscow and frankly it surprised him
walking this backwards America was
losing a cold war because in great part
the American economy had fallen apart in
great part because America had lost his
spiritual moorings Reagan always
believed that this country operated on a
higher moral plane than any other
country in history because if it's
faith-based origins and limitless
horizons some called it manifest destiny
spirituality and economic growth make
for a confident and strong foreign
policy each was interconnected with the
other and they were inseparable and all
this emanated from his devotion to
freedom is the organizing philosophy of
this new Republican Party beginning in
1977 don't let anyone tell you otherwise
but Ron Reagan was a true populace in
the best interpretation of the word and
was the tea party before the Tea Party
came into existence he was always
suspicious of the concentration of power
by both government and corporate
corporate America Reagan did not arrive
at this philosophy all by himself Bill
Buckley once said in the 1960s he said
quote I will not cede more power to the
state I will not willingly see power to
anyone not to the state not to General
Motors not to the CIO I will hoard my
power like a miser I will then use my
power as I see fit I mean to live my
life as an obedient man but obedient to
God subservient to the wisdom of my
ancestors never to the authority of
political truths arrived at yesterday at
the voting booth Reagan himself said
1977 about conservatism he said our task
was not to sell a philosophy but to make
the majority of Americans who already
share that philosophy see that modern
conservatism offers them a political
home we are not a cult we are members of
a majority let's act and talk like it
the job is ours the job must be done if
not by us who if not now when our party
must be the party of the individual it
must not sell out the individual to
cater to the group no greater challenge
faces our society than today than
ensuring that each one of us can
maintain his
dignity and his identity in an
increasingly complex centralized society
extreme taxation excessive controls
oppressive government competition with
business galloping inflation frustrated
minorities and forgotten Americans are
not the product of free enterprise they
are the residue of centralized
bureaucracy of government by a
self-anointed elite our party must be
based on the kind of leadership that
grows and takes its strength from the
people any organization is an actuality
only the length and shadow of its
members a political party is a
mechanical structure created to further
a cause the cause not the mechanism
brings and holds the members together
and our cause must be to rediscover
reinsert and reapply American spiritual
heritage to our national affairs then
with God's help we shall indeed be as a
city upon a hill with the eyes of all
people upon us close quote these are the
thoughts and words of a man who took the
presidency seriously and as a serious
concern and by a man who was seriously
concerned about the future of his
country the scholarship associated with
writing his speech and his commentaries
and his offices are helping us to better
understand how deep with the man thought
about things how refined his philosophy
of freedom was and how much he believed
in enlightenment and that a natural
aristocracy of Americans unaided by the
heavy hand or nobility or government
could indeed make a world over again
this explains why Reagan was such an
admirer of Thomas Paine although he also
deeply admired the weeks of Alexander
Solzhenitsyn rasam there's a
contradiction souls in each some decried
the Enlightenment that put man at the
center of the universe but Reagan
believed that man is a divinely inspired
creature was simply doing God's work in
that universe and he often spoke of man
with God Reagan never liked false
arguments he didn't like false choices
he could synthesize the positions of
Thomas Paine Ansel's and Ethan and
because of that philosophy the road to
the White House was screwed in many
hazards for Reagan it goes quite frankly
there were not enough people in this
country or not
out of people in the Republican Party
who understood unlike most or all of us
here understood what he was about as
recently as two weeks after his election
as governor of California began thinking
about running for the Oval Office but as
are as already discussed he lost to
Richard Nixon in 1968 in 1975 he saw
President Gerald Ford is continuing many
of those policies of Nixon's which he
had opposed and decided to make his
revolutionary bid to oust incumbent
president making the most serious
challenge since Teddy Roosevelt had
attempted to rest the nomination from
witty Howard Taft in 1912 with all the
assets of the White House and the
Republican Party and other institutions
of the time arrayed against him he came
astonishingly close losing the
nomination afford by just a handful of
Delegates out of 2257 cast in Kansas
City in August of 1976 Reagan lost the
nomination by less than 60 delegate
votes overall told of his radical
insurgency we have to some of us here
remember that reagan in nineteen seventy
six wasn't treated by the elites the way
they treat him today even as today they
don't understand him although we did
understand him and when they did
understand him it was it was a
revelation even though i remember
reading these editorials of the time and
laughing is that they acted like they
just discovered a cure for cancer or
something the new york times in 1976
wrote this about ronald reagan there
have been many dramatic battles over
presidential nominations in the past but
never in modern times have there been
any a'those of anything like this a
sitting president two years in office
being challenged to within an inch of
his political life by the opposition
inside of his own party it seems almost
impossible that with all the advantages
of incumbency and none of the
disadvantages of personal scandal this
president could in fact lose the
nomination as well as control of his own
party but this he nearly did we have to
remember those clothes in a close quote
we have to remember what the GOP was
like in 1976 and a lot of us do it was
not the Reaganite party many of us it is
today it was instead of party dominated
by moderates and liberals like Nelson
Rockefeller and a fellow named Romney
who's governor of the state nelson
rockford jacob javits for reagan to take
over the republican party who would
first have to remake it Time magazine
also had the same revelation that the
New York Times did in 1976 about
Reagan's insurgent candidacy they said
that the Gipper's campaign had been
quote extraordinary he was seen by many
as shallow and simplistic and even
dangerous all but a handful of senators
and congressmen shunned him he was
opposed by nearly every state
organization and yet when it was all
over Reagan virtually alone had
collected several hundred thousand more
votes than the president in the
contested primaries the popular
explanation was that as its opponent
Ford was dull but Reagan on his own had
surely touched a public nerve Reagan's
philosophy in 1976 however was still not
completely formed it took the ideas of
another great conservative Jack Kemp to
give Reagan the final piece of the
puzzle to make his new optimistic
conservatism complete with the idea of
radical tax cuts radical personal tax
cuts the Republican Party had always
been associated with business tax cuts
but this is a radical new idea to join
his faith family based policies and
other radicals and the other radical
idea of defeating Soviet Communism and
not merely coexisting with it he went
before the American people in 1980
offering a robust and coherent
philosophy of shifting power away from
Washington and back to the citizenry we
debate this openly now but 30 years ago
this is revolutionary thinking both
parties at the time were enamored of
government it's just that the Democrats
were more enamored of government
although Richard Nixon did give them a
run for their money from nineteen sixty
eight to nineteen seventy-four the
Democrats when it came were they had it
hands down though when it came to
creating bigger and more intrusive
centralized Authority the world by 1980
was a mess after years of losing Wars
and losing presidents and losing jobs
and homes for the first time in American
history parents did not believe the
future would be better for the children
that it had been for them into this
breach
Regan those nomination was no walk in
the park he had many many opponents
especially in the country clubs and the
corporate boardrooms of the GOP all of
whom supported either John Connolly or
George Bush Reagan was the target of
slurs and innuendos from many in his own
party who were posed to him because he
was too old or too conservative or too
strident or to this or to that in
January of 1980 reg and astonishment
lost to george bush in the iowa caucuses
a state were 40 years earlier he was
known to everybody as Dutch and a state
which was dear to his heart and which he
visited often except when it was most
important in those two years leading up
to the caucuses he and his campaigns in
attendance to Iowa and the primaries
nearly cost him the nomination only
after taking control of his own campaign
did he take control of his own destiny
after a spirited and tough primary
battle he won the nomination on his
third try but elements and the GOP still
made things difficult simply because
they did not understand him after all
this was a man who once said quote I do
not want to go back to the past I want
to go back to the past way of looking at
the future this is a man who spoke of a
community of shared values as you saw in
the video tape this is a man who quietly
said in 1980 that it wasn't about
wanting to be present but mores maybe
was about one should be President this
was man who said 1980 this is no longer
a campaign it is a crusade to save this
country but it was also a man with a
remarkable and wonderful sense of humor
once as governor he was confronted by a
smelly hippie carrying a sign science
says said make love not war the smelly
hippie may have been Bill Clinton I'm
not sure the sign said make love not war
Reagan looked at the sign and looked at
the smelly hip and he turned to an eight
he says you know from the looks of him I
don't think he could do either
Reagan always referred to himself as a
citizen politician because he truly
believed in the concept his 1976
campaign was called citizens for Reagan
his political organization was called
citizens for the Republic and when he
opened the proceedings in Detroit 1980
he peeled to the Republicans by saying
my fellow citizens Reagan understood the
genius of the founders that power flows
upward from the citizenry to the elected
officials through all his years he
gained an insight and honed a philosophy
that was based upon the most fundamental
period of the founding fathers that
power truly resides with the mandiant
not the few that elected officials were
truly public servants who had a solemn
compact a solemn compact with those who
put them into power and the first
obligation of the national government
was to secure the peace and freedom for
those who allowed them to govern them
Reagan understood the quintessential
American because he was the
quintessential American even as of the
debate with Jimmy Carter 1980 though
just one week before the November
elections reagan did not trim his sails
he attacked carter centralized policies
but turned the criticism into praise for
a solo country he said quote what no
this is 1980 this is this is one week
before the election know that Nixon's
always advised her Republicans was
tacked to the right to win the
nomination then tacked to the middle to
get voters in the middle but Reagan
would have any of it this is what he
said in the debate one week before the
election he said that Washington has
deserved power and autonomy and
authority that belongs back to the state
and local level it is imposed on the
individual freedoms of the people and
that there are more of these things that
could be solved by the people themselves
if they were given a chance or by the
levels of government that were closer to
them close quote even with all that had
gone before even with the sorry
condition of America in the world as of
late November 1980 harder was still
astonishingly ahead in the polls only by
taking matters into his own hands and
debating Carter did Reagan finally
closed the sale with the American voter
and used just saw it here his line where
he says are you better off and a lot of
us from
where we were when we saw that there
were a lot of people who are on the
fence at that point you know Carter had
run a successful campaign just trying to
destroy Ronald Reagan painting a mess up
you know it's a nuclear cowboy who was
and he said he said this is a direct
quote he said he was going to divide
America black from white christian from
jew and north from South he ran probably
the most vicious campaign in American
history until next year when Barack
Obama runs the most vicious campaign in
American history because that's the only
way mr. Obama's going to win but Reagan
it didn't run a very good campaign in
the fall is only until the last couple
days and then in this campaign and this
debate where he says looked in the
camera and 118 million people saw him
say are you better off than you were
four years ago and for millions of
Democrats and independents that was that
they realized that Reagan understood
what it was they were going in the
president simply didn't by the way that
debate was and remains the most watched
presidential debate in American history
now think about it that was when we were
a nation of 240 million people now we're
a nation of 306 million people and yet
more people watch that debate between
Jimmy Carter Ronald Reagan than watch
the debates between Barack Obama and
John McCain or between for that matter
between John Kennedy and Richard Nixon
1960 Reagan won in an astonishing
landslide over Carter of the campaign
and this summed up well the difference
between Jimmy Carter Ronald Reagan an
observer said that if you ask Jimmy
Carter what time does he tell you how to
build a watch and if you have to run a
regular time it is he tell you it's time
to get this country moving again and old
day a Jeff Bell once wrote quote Reagan
and variably gravitated toward the
aspects of American conservatism that
were optimistic not cynical populist not
elitist egalitarian not hierarchical
moral and not relativistic in short what
is distinctly American in America and
conservatism the meaning of the 1980
campaign was validated in the election
of 1984 we didn't know the meeting of
the 1980 campaign until reagan won and
84 just that we won't know
meaning of 2008 until the two thousand
twelve elections the 1980 represent a
fundamental shift in American history
OHS is simply a detour as we found out
in 1984 the detour was the election of
Carter 1976 while the election of Reagan
was the focal point of change or no in
this country from 1800 up until two
thousand eight every generation or till
we've had a epochal addict election that
is like what cue ball hitting an eight
ball and setting it up in a wildly
different direction the election of 1800
sends the country off in a radically
different direction the election of 1828
Jackson the rise of Jackson's policies
1860 certainly 1932 with the advent and
the new deal and then of course 1980
with Reagan each of these are part of a
dielectric of American history the chain
dramatically and permanently alters the
arc of history of America the question
was was that in 76 and 80 was Carter the
game changer or in 76 it was Reagan the
game changer an ad we found out that
Carter was a detour in history and now
30 years after that the 1980 election
were confronted again with the election
of 2008 was the election of barack obama
detour and histories he a game-changer
we won't know the meaning of it until
2012 all reagan's campaigns had their
ups and downs their entries and
confrontations even some got testy
sometimes Reagan got testy just before
the New Hampshire primary his then
campaign manager John Sears was
attempting to oust a Denise from the
campaign the meeting dragged down to the
wee hours until reagan it had enough he
jumped out his chair and yelled at Sears
you're not going to get ed by God Reagan
started toward sears like he was going
to punch him this is true story and it
was only after Charlie black stood be
put himself between the two men mrs.
Reagan was talking on Reagan on one side
saying Ronnie Ronnie come away and jim
lake and Charlie black were tugging on
John
sears did they prevent serious from get
it from Reagan well punching his lights
out basically if I focus too much on the
ideas in the philosophy of the Reagan
campaigns it's because that was the
things he was thinking about these were
the things he was thinking about today's
campaigns are all about the consultants
and tactics and the media while the rest
of a star for a greater understanding
from those campaigns of strategies and
thoughts if you think Reagan's campaigns
were different that's because you're
right if you think its campaigns we're
more consequential than the campaign's
of late you're right I would be happy to
answer any questions you might have
about the more gossipy aspects to the
campaigns during the Q&A if you would
like but I would be but let me leave you
with this we all appreciate the legacy
of Ronald Reagan but if we needed a
confirmation let it come from his
enemies Mikhail Gorbachev I did I know
here at Hillsdale we know whom with the
conclusion of the Cold War was not that
it was co mutually settled between
Moscow and Washington we know what
happened is is that Reagan basically put
the neck of Soviet Communism under his
cowboy heel and crushed life out of it
no Soviet leader has ever given up
willing had given up power from 1917
until nineteen ninety-one until
Gorbachev surrenders from 1917 until
nineteen eighty-one the Soviets gained
ground against every American present
until nineteen eighty-one as her call
something happened in January of
nineteen eighty-one even Mikhail
Gorbachev said that Reagan won the Cold
War and did not simply end it the
confusion comes because so many American
Historians live in Manhattan in Boston
the truth be told is there more
communists on the Upper West Side and in
Boston that never wore in the Politburo
but also from John Patrick Diggins a
liberal historian and historian of
liberalism in America who died recently
Diggins was in many ways the official
historian of the labor in liberal
movements in America in the 20th century
he been at Berkeley in the 1960s doing
battle would then Governor Reagan it yet
in his last book the title was Ronald
Reagan fate freedom the making of his
now this is a book remember written by
essentially a card-carrying member of
the American Left labor small C
communist philosophy movement that was
prevalent in America college campuses
all from the 30s up to the 60s I got to
know John briefly helping him with this
book before he passed away some years
ago but in that book he called Reagan
this is the liberal again called Reagan
one of the four greatest presidents long
said Washington Lincoln and Franklin
Roosevelt Reagan Diggins said had the
imagination to see a world without the
Menace of communism he wrote quote
Reagan had the imagination to envision a
country without high taxes and the
bureaucratic state and a world without
the threat of communism close quote
Reagan was one of the four greatest
presidents he said because Diggins
criteria was all the all these four men
liberated a great many people George
Washington liberated many people Freya
Abraham Lincoln who liberated many
people Franklin Roosevelt liberated many
people in a Ronald Reagan Liberator many
people and that was his criteria for
greatness Diggins also answer the
question which historians upon dritt
since the time of Henry Adams does the
man make the times as do the money man
the times make the man he came to the
conclusion that of course that is what I
think will agree the man makes the times
as he left office in January of 1980 I
and his old adversary the Washington
Post and I mean adversary was compelled
to say that I'm his watch something
quote substantive occurred the paper
elaborated quote Ronald Reagan has
absolutely confounded prediction today
at age 77 he relinquished his
relinquishes the office so many people
thought he could never get being it was
said to as being said eight years ago
too old to ideological too conservative
too poorly informed too politically
marginal and short to out of it but
there he is going out in a rare end of
the term surge of good feeling his
critics on key issues we are in fatica
Lee among them still at a loss to
explain it to assess and finally even
understand the man facts alone should
help lay to rest the intellectual
condescend
with which so many of his political
wrestling partners and victims have
discussed him he has helped make this
country stronger abroad and a different
one at home mr. Reagan has left a
powerful imprint on American politics
his was a consequential presidency close
quote upon his death in june of nineteen
of june of 2005 Russian dissident
Alexander Solzhenitsyn said quote in
July of 1975 I concluded my remarks in
the reception room of the US Senate with
these words all too soon your government
will need not just extraordinary men but
men with greatness bind them in your
souls find them in your hearts find them
within the breadth and depth of your
homeland five years later I was
overjoyed when just such a man came to
the White House made the soft earth be a
cushion in his present rest close quote
upon becoming president 1981 Ronald
Reagan changed the Republican Party
Ronald Reagan changed America and Ronald
Reagan changed the world and the rest as
they say is history thank
thank you so much mr. Shirley just so
you folks know there will be a book
signing out in the lobby of his book
rendezvous with destiny Ronald Reagan in
the campaign that changed America and we
have time for a few questions we do ask
though that you wait for the microphone
before you actually ask your question so
with that if anybody has one
nineteen eighty Detroit Convention the
pro-life positions first port put forth
as a plank in the platform of the
Republican Party's that correct yeah
that's correct actually the it had been
there was a pro-choice plank in there in
1976 in Kansas City that Betty Ford and
insisted be put there as in addition to
a pro as you recall pro er er a plank in
the platform in 76 both those came out
mainly because well because of Reagan
and because the phyllis schlafly they
both came out in the party has ever
since had a pro-life plank in the
platform after you comment on what
effect that has had since then well i am
i own my own view on well we have four
children so i guess you probably can
guess what our position is how the life
issue is look you know that it took a
long time for abolitionists to achieve
their view of limiting slavery in this
country it took you know for some you
know hundreds of years i hope it doesn't
take that long for the pro-life view to
succeed i know we're on the right side i
mean we know we're on the right side
history tells us we're on the right side
we it is an abomination it is a is a
scourge it is a terrible thing and I
think eventually that we're going to win
and I think we're going to win because
not only we're right we're morally right
and eventually we're going to be
politically
I I think you stated that somewhere in
1980 whether it was a de nominating
process or the election that the
established the Republican establishment
did not understand Reagan right is that
possible and the reason the reason I
asked the question is is it if is it a
failure to understand or an inability to
exercise control Reagan was a threat to
the establishment yeah Vega was a threat
and and there were elements that didn't
understand him and then there were
elements who thought they understood him
all too well it was cultural it was
ideological it was philosophical he
would he campaigned against the
corporate boardrooms in the country club
image he talked about a new Republican
Party there would be the party of the of
the cop on the beat of the farmer of the
housewife of the people who all they
wanted from government was basically
they want to pay their taxes they wanted
to be left alone but it was a party that
would ASSU the Washington buddy system
that the Republican Party had become
comfortable with even you know well some
of them did so because and that's why
they tried to destroy him we worked at
the Republican National Committee my
wife and I worked at the Republican
National Committee in the early 80s
because quite frankly because it was a
nest of of moderate liberal Republicans
and they were the Reagan White House was
furious Linda off singer was furious
because before any conservatives weren't
a Reagan i'ts working at the Republican
National Committee when a Reagan I was
sitting in the Oval Office and so they
and when we got in there we were still
in the minority there was a there was a
woman whose name will go unmentioned but
after the 82 election when we lost seats
the republicans lost seats and the in
the offseason this woman at the
Republican National Committee put up a
sign on the door to her office and it's
a sign up here for the 1984 George Bush
for president committee now this is 1982
yes yes yes there's also again I won't
mention his name because he's very
prominent in Washington in the
Republican Party in the congressional
leadership he's a staffer in 1984 that I
mean everybody's for Reagan on 1984
except that there were a small group of
liberal and moderate Republicans who
were down in Dallas protesting Reagan
and the news reports of the time talked
about the convention delegates booing
them and telling them to go to Moscow
which music to my ears but uh but anyway
is that there were always elements of
the party that opposed Ronald Reagan
from from the 50s right up until right
up until today and he's seeing playing
being played out today you know Mitt
Romney tried to run against Ted Kennedy
by saying look want me to denounce
Ronald Reagan get electric of the Senate
I'll denounce Ronald Reagan so there's
still people in the party who don't get
Reagan and never will
mr. Shirley as we're talking earlier
would you care to just expand a little
bit about maybe similarities or
differences that you see between
President Reagan or our current
president my father once said that when
you so many hangs a fastball on your
head and your face you have a moral
obligation to hit it out of the park
while I'm respectful of Barack Obama's
president obama's political skills I
written I wrote a column several months
ago which I said he was the nation's
first Facebook president and but think
about is that I wasn't being you know
sarcastic is this that is was being
analytical is this is a man who wrote
not one but two autobiographies well put
his name on the dust jacket of two
autobiographies before he was 45 years
of age and really without accomplishing
anything in his life he uses every
sentence with a personal pronoun
possessive pronoun it's III my
administration my cabinet my White House
you know as many complaints as i have
about john kennedy at least he
understood the presidency he didn't say
my he didn't say my government he said
this government he said your government
ronald reagan always said your
government he said this government this
administration your white house but they
never talked as if they owned it is I
Obama is is just mean obviously there's
a lot of talent there but it's unused
it's untapped and I think quite frankly
is is that he is so caught up in the
arrogance of himself that he refuses to
think that he could be wrong about
anything and thinks that anybody who
opposes him is somehow not just wrong
but vile this dangerous dangerous
combination there in his philosophy it's
it's essentially it's it's arrogance and
ignorance combined to form
Obama is Amit I think it's very very
it's very it's very bad for the country
you know that Harry Truman once said the
job of the president is to say yes and
no but mostly no Obama has never learned
that lesson of Truman to say that you
mostly that he has to say no and we do
have time for just one more question
I was just curious obviously himself and
then the first later probably his
closest advisors but in the election or
the campaign who did he rely on one or
two people that he relied on the most
for that election for sage advice 1580
yes ed Meese that means I'd me he said
me said nice yeah I was once asked to
Hawaii would first turn a crisis and he
said ed Meese I think that he wasn't as
alter ego but he who's this close to
alter ego as you as you could imagine I
mean he was there were there was the
Californians who were around Ronald
Reagan we're very very close to him you
know Stu Spencer Mike Deaver Peter
hannaford Linda noffsinger others but
probably he was he was like Peter that
he was first among equals in that he'd
gone back to 66 with Ronald Reagan was
there in Sacramento with Ronald Reagan
was there all through the 70s was there
in the White House was really somebody
reg and knew that he could trust
somebody he could ask his advice
somebody he knew that would not leak or
talk to the press about his private
conversations that there was enormous
enormous enormous respect and trust
there for Reagan there were others too
Jim Baker was an unsung hero the ad
campaign he's the one who devised the
came over from the Bush campaign to the
Reagan campaign after in Detroit and
devised the debate strategy didn't to
get all the negotiation handled
everything and actually de Baker's
credit he had more confidence it was a
great great debate inside the Reagan
campaign over whether or not Ronald
Reagan should even in fact debate Jimmy
Carter because there was even even
people who had known breagan for years
still had doubts about his capacity you
know in a presidential debate which is
it's in my book and I'm kind of repeat a
vulgarity if it's in my book but it is
that this
I how God doing it is that the people
who didn't understand Reagan and Stu
Spencer told me I said I said tell me
how in those weeks in those days after
he's you know Carter's pounding Reagan
he's going to call variance a war he's
going to do this he's going to do this
it just it was a vicious mean spirited
campaign he's a racist all this and I
said I asked to I said how did he feel
about Carter and how did he feel about
going on stage with Carter and he says
you know look Reagan at that point this
is October 1980 he didn't see Carter as
leader of the free world he didn't see
Carter's president I states he saw
Carter's a little ship
thank you very much thank you everybody
you